there were a lot of moments where it
looked like my personality had
disappeared
[Laughter]
i was hard to reach and i
didn't communicate but the overall
change they would say i've become the
woman that i deserve to be
oh gosh what was this
all right um this was my speech
oh this was written july i was invited
to meet camilla this was when i
initially teamed up with refuge
i'm a woman who experienced abuse
but i stand here not as a victim
but as a survivor
some would say i was the class clown so
i always came with the jokes always came
with the banter um i was friends of
absolutely everyone and anyone who was
willing to be my friend
[Music]
it started off um you know you meet
someone for the first time you get to
know them
bubbly personality bouncing back and
forth you know the energy
i just thought this person is an amazing
person but
quite quickly into that things kind of
just changed initially it was quite easy
to ignore small things maybe
shoving me if i said something or you
know kicking me if i spoke back to them
and they weren't happy
after i'd say about
10 to 12 months things start started to
take a turn where i couldn't ignore it
anymore there was one specific incident
where
i had literally done
what i would say absolutely nothing i
had nudged them
as i was passing them
and that was a disrespect
and they completely lashed out where
they repeatedly were just hitting me
hitting me hitting me hitting me
i did not tell anyone about it
for a period of time i felt embarrassed
i was like how do i bring this up
i eventually did go to the police and i
told them everything and it took about
five hours
detailing every incident and that's when
things started from there after five
months erica had heard nothing back from
the police then in september 2020 she
found out why
although she'd spent hours giving
evidence they were never going to be
able to look into it anyway they said oh
sorry we just looked at the date of the
incident that you wanted to report and
it looks like we won't be able to do
anything anyway
and i said why
and they said there's a six month time
limit on reporting
common assault i felt so hopeless and
helpless and
broken
i called my friend
um bless her she picks up straight away
and i just told her everything whilst
crying to her on the phone
and i said i have to do something about
this i i'm not the sort of person just
to just sit on things or to accept
things i rather i would rather act and
if that action can lead to a result that
benefits other people that's the most
important thing to me so within 10
minutes i knew i needed to change this
law
and i spent the next three four days
just sitting in my room i don't i don't
even think i left my house at this point
i don't think any domestic violence
victims should be told after six months
that they were too late that's what this
campaign is about we fight for change
erica had done a lot of the work already
she started the petition she had set up
a campaign but she needed that help to
to get more attention
on it and to to make sure politicians
were aware of the problem and the need
to act so we were delighted when erica
got in touch with us to ask for our
support i alongside refuge women's aid
and the center of women's justice are
urging the government to extend these
time limits what i wanted to do using
refugees platform was to be the voice
for the people who had shared their
stories or even if they hadn't who knew
they had gone through these things and i
said oh my gosh i have this campaign
let's work together i've already got a
lot of people behind me you have a lot
of people behind me if we collide these
two worlds we'd be unstoppable let's
talk to erica osakuis a student an
organizer and survivor of domestic
violence it is about a perpetrator
saying to a young woman like erica oh
good luck nothing's going to happen
erica starquay who set up a campaign
group for victims of violence it made me
feel hopeful i think that's the first
time i really felt hope and i had hoped
that something was really going to be
done and it was from there where all
these doors opened up yvette cooper's
stepping in and the journey began
in particular i wanted to raise new
claws 69 in my name the purpose of this
amendment is to get justice for victims
of domestic abuse who are being timed
out i drew up an amendment to the police
and courts bill to actually put forward
that amendment in parliament there is a
time limit on justice that most victims
are not aware of of six months from the
offense even though in domestic abuse
cases it may take many months for good
reason for victims to feel able to go to
the police i worked with baroness helen
knew love in the house of lords the
timeline in his current farm is putting
victims in harm's way she also did the
same thing in the house of lords to draw
up an amendment to keep the pressure on
the government and we just kept the
pressure up an unfair six-month time
limit there's a six-month
limit for charges being brought the six
months time limit until finally
haven't we forced them to agree that
this had to change
on the 4th of january 2022 the law
changed a time limit to report domestic
abuse has extended from 6 months to 2
years
erica stood where i'm standing now
and with humility and profound courage
told us how she'd used her experience of
an abusive relationship to campaign
successfully to change the law
this was not just a win for me but a win
for every single person that had been
let down and the impact it had on so
many people and so many lives in that
moment the day i shared that news
was astonishing completely mind-blowing
this law change will make a real
difference there will be thousands of
survivors every year most of them women
who
if they decide to can report the assault
that they've experienced at the hands of
their perpetrator to the police and
won't need to fear that the police are
going to say
sorry we can't do anything because of a
very short six-month time limit that
doesn't reflect the realities of
domestic abuse
sky news sent out foi requests to every
police force in england the 29 forces
who responded said that in the first
five months of 2022 8245
incidents of domestic abuse had been
reported between six months and two
years after the abuse took place
that means that already over 8 000
incidents of domestic violence are now
being dealt with by the police because
of erica and campaigners like her
there was moments where i knew i wanted
to give up where i just wanted to
crawl into my bed and never come out and
never fight for anything i didn't think
that my voice had any meaning or
strength or power nothing i wish i
valued myself more back then and realize
more that
i am powerful a few weeks ago
the government announced that the
six-month time limit was to be increased
for survivors of domestic abuse
me a young woman from london
i changed the law
you know i don't think i've said that
much that might be like the third time
i've said that out loud
so yeah it's weird saying it but yeah
wow